[Music]
tracy is with us in memphis hi tracy how
are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
uh my husband and i have a rental
property
in south carolina that we would like to
sell
it currently has renters in it their
lease is up in december
and our property manager is telling us
that due to
covid the renters do not have to let
anyone
into the home so
for a personal health issue they have
decided they don't want anyone in the
house not even to take pictures so we
can post it online
so my husband and i were thinking about
talking to some of these
investment groups that keep calling and
want to buy our house
but we were hoping to get some wisdom on
that situation before we started it
because we haven't done this
we never sold a home period so i think i
would go to an endorsed local provider
like i was just talking about at ramsey
solutions and
find one of those in their areas i don't
know
anything about the uh current status of
covet restrictions in south carolina but
i'm calling bs
i was gonna say is that even legal like
can they even do that
does your lease not have the right to
inspect the property
uh i would have to read it i think
i think you have a wish for a property
manager
okay but i do have the spiritual gift of
cynicism so
uh i might be wrong okay but i'm first
calling that because
i'm kind of like old school like if i
own a house i'd like to go in at any
time i want
within reason they have the right under
the law of what's called quiet enjoyment
meaning i don't get to harass
them but for them to stiff arm you call
covid
when there's not really a coveted
problem at their house
uh i'm just thinking this is a bunch of
crap so i think your elp
a good real estate agent who would have
an incentive to help you sell the house
could probably give you more accurate
information you may need to fire your
property manager
okay i just i that would make me
frustrated yeah approaching it
approaching angry
yeah approaching angry you're you're a
little more gentle this hour
you know i mean it would i'm just trying
to think i mean i wouldn't
now if they've got a sick child or the
the person's in chemo
or something that i'm gonna have a lot
of compassion and i'll back off of that
stance
but if they're just being butts and
using covid to be a butt
then i can help you with your butt
problem you know
i'll remove your butt right and so
that's
that's a possibility uh i
it just doesn't make sense i i uh now it
could be south carolina has some
crazy butt just sticking with the theme
here with it
yeah uh but uh uh uh regulation on the
books right
it's possible yeah but i mean we we most
places had like
moratoriums on eviction last summer
for a while some areas have got more
lengthy moratoriums of eviction
we had one in our area that lasted for i
don't know 90 days or something
and um i had one tenant go crazy start
beating his wife and all this she had to
leave
i had to get him out of there because i
don't deal with people like that very
well
i don't have any tolerance for that kind
of white trash and so
um this expensive house
but anyway they they i couldn't get him
out because of stinking
coven moratorium on evicting people uh
but it had nothing to do with covet it
had to do with who's an idiot
right so uh but anyway you still idiots
were protected too
under it so um but the that's that's the
kind of stuff runs through my head
tracy as a landlord for 30 years that uh
first and foremost now again i'm also
the other side of that is if someone is
in need we have the ability to be very
compassionate and very
slow and i'm certainly not trying to
bring harm to someone on the other hand
so i need more information about why
these people are stiff arming you
if i'm you and i need more information
about this law and i'm going to check
with an elp and find that out because i
think your
property manager is full of crap i could
be wrong
now you people from south carolina y'all
can all write me right now and go oh
there's a law dave you don't know what
you're talking about because
i don't know what i'm talking about i'm
just saying it
just smells like tenant misbehavior not
covid related
so yeah is there any element of the
property manager has no motivation
because they want to continue to manage
the property yeah
or they're one of these companies that
doesn't want to ruffle any feathers
which really you shouldn't be in
property management if you don't want to
ruffle feathers because
it's kind of like the definition of
property management you ruffle feathers
for a living
you collect rent and you move renters
along that don't you know and
this is what you do right this is the
feather ruffling business right so
i feel like you're in a similar business
dave you just ruffle feathers on the
show
all day every day all right we're just
gonna start that that's our new that's
our new thing everybody do your fingers
okay
oh the youtube people are the only ones
understand what we're talking about oh
my gosh
yeah the uh yeah yeah just calls a
ruckus
but i um no i don't think you have to
give the house away
my first step is not to give it away at
wholesale to an investor who doesn't
even need to see the inside
because what they're going to do is buy
the house as cheap as they can
to cover the fact that they don't know
what's inside what they're getting into
are these people in there running a
crack house and you know they're going
to burn the thing down
or are they in there they got 73 cats
and you're gonna have to strip
out the plywood all the way down to the
joists because there's no getting a cat
smell out of a property
and so that kind of stuff i mean what
have you got in there what's going on in
there that they don't want you in there
or are they just trying to be hard to
get along with because
you know but you there there's a limited
thing depending on what your lease says
and depending on what south carolina
actually has
as a regulation but i
i think you're onto something with the
property manager i really do i think
all shucks they won't let us in sorry
anyway
you see okay remember all those nine
million times people out there
that i tell you don't do long distance
landlording
i've never heard you say that don't do
long-distance landlording
remember that that's it right there
he says it every day everyone every time
someone calls with a house out of town
i say don't do it that's it that's the
reason right there i don't know how
tracy got in this mess bless her heart
she's a sweet lady
and um those folks that are living there
are lucky they have tracy
yeah because i'm not as compassionate
unless i need to be compassionate and
then i can be compassionate but i'm
i'm just not going to be well and
there's an element too of this
aside from even if they do learn there's
stuff you got to do to get the house
ready to sell and not just take pictures
you got to make it
look presentable for well you can't go
in and start rehabbing a house with a
tenant in there that's not legal i mean
you have to wait till they leave to get
it ready but um
but for them zero access
yeah a little well not in most states
now maybe in the
socialist republic of california or
something like that it's possible there
or maybe one of these other areas where
you know the laws are just wacky but
most states have
reasonable tenant protections and
reasonable owner
landlord right protections right and
there's a way that the law interfaces to
create
a fair transaction a fair
uh justice and mercy can be both
implemented there in a way where
yes compassion is available but
not if you're just misbehaving within
reason well hopefully an elp will help
her
and then she can get it sold and not
have this long distance rental and not
have to deal with it anymore there we go
she said she's getting on the market in
december but this is june oh yeah yeah
it's a bit of a bit of a waste
um yeah i'm wondering
if there's man damn i'll start to get
yeah that's good
i think i think we got her on the run
there that's good